so i'm pretty nervous to talk about this
right now
[Music]
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by wild and
we will be answering a bit of a
controversial question that i get
daily and that is my thoughts on
how to sustainably lose weight
yep we're going there and we're going
there
right now oh it's already been brought
well
almost now so first a quick note about
my sponsor
wild now when i was pregnant with e i
started using
natural deodorant but honestly i found
that most of them that i tried actually
made me
smell worse that smells like pure
gasoline
so i was really excited to try out
wild's natural deodorant especially
because
of its unique sustainability efforts so
first of all
wild is aluminum and paraben free and
because it's not an antiperspirant
it doesn't clog pores most importantly
though
it actually works like it is barely
summer now and i am
fixing profusely already and my husband
has not complained about me
smelling so i say that's a huge win but
they have a
bunch of scents all of which are really
lovely my favorite being
the lemon meringue and orange zest what
i also love is that you get a reusable
customizable case that you can then
refill with different scents each month
so
it's a uniquely sustainable choice even
the refill packaging
is made out of bamboo and is 100
biodegradable so that you can just
chuck it into the compost when you're
done the best news is that they ship
worldwide and you can choose a one-off
purchase
or subscription so if you want to give
wild a try check out the link in the
description
and use my promo code abby for 20
off of your order now before we get into
it with my top tips
i want to preface this video with a
reminder that
like my content on intuitive eating this
is not going to be
for everyone specifically this content
is
not intended for folks with complicated
histories with food
or disordered eating i know that a lot
of people with eating disorder histories
still often do want to lose weight and
that is a completely valid
desire but i strongly urge you to seek
out the support
of a healthcare provider and not get
advice from a generalized
youtube video like this and ultimately
that really goes for everyone
i also want to mention that dietitians
and other wellness professionals
like myself generally think and operate
along
a weight loss haze continuum
some of my colleagues will not work with
clients who desire weight loss
while others only work with clients
looking to lose weight
i kind of live in the gray i mean i
believe in
client-centered care and also
evidence-based informed
practice so i personally would rather
someone who wanted to lose weight seek
out the support
of an evidence-based dietitian then they
fall for extreme
fad diets that they see online and this
is even more important
when weight loss efforts would be really
dangerous
and that dietitian could potentially
have the training
to help the client pivot to other acts
of self-care
now i also need to of course mention
that despite people's
best efforts weight loss is never
inevitable it's not a behavior
so it's not something directly within
our control
so i don't believe that any dietitian
coach nutritionist or
trainer can help you lose
weight it's kind of unethical to even
suggest that we can
we can give you some tips and tools to
shift behaviors
but it's really up to your body to
decide what to do
it's for this reason that i often
suggest that we take the focus
off of the end goal of an arbitrary
weight loss number and
focus instead on health-promoting
behaviors
behaviors that we can actually control
behaviors
that have some evidence associating them
with
weight loss for some folks so with that
said
i want to share with you a more gentle
nutrition approach
and set of tips that i would share with
a client
patient friend or family member who
desired weight loss
and wanted to do so in the most
sustainable way
possible i also chatted a bit with my
colleague and friend abby langer
author of the new book good food bad
diet
so you will see a few little excerpts
from her as well
all right folks let's get into it
tip number one think about what you can
add
not what you should be taking away most
of the fad diets out there
focus on eliminating certain foods or
food groups from our diet
gluten sugar dairy booze i mean we're
always cutting something out
and cutting out foods you love often
works in the short term but very quickly
we burn out give in and eat
all the forbidden foods when we let
ourselves fall into this
scarcity mentality we go on a bit of a
rebellious streak that makes us want
what we can't have
even more so i prefer to stop thinking
about what we're taking away
and focus instead on what we're adding
to our diet
so maybe we're making a point to add a
serving of salad with our sandwich
lunch or add a source of protein like
greek yogurt
to our bowl of cereal at breakfast we'll
get more into the specifics of
what to add in some of my next tips but
the point
is that even if we don't consciously
think about cutting foods out adding in
satiating foods often helps us edge out
some of the less nutritious
less satiating foods for example when
you have a protein rich
breakfast rather than just simple carbs
at breakfast
you're less likely to find yourself
snacking on the powdered donuts
in the office before lunch the result is
that you often end up consuming fewer
calories
without even noticing that you're doing
it this
little mindset tweak of imagining
abundance
rather than denial is often enough to
keep people more dedicated
and motivated to stick to a healthy new
habit
and this brings me to tip number two get
in that hunger crushing
combination my long-term subbies know
i'm talking about fiber protein and
healthy fat
feeling satiated longer is valuable for
most people because
you're not you when you're hungry but
when it comes to weight loss
specifically
satiety is key it's really hard to
create any kind of caloric deficit
if you feel like eating your own arm off
but
each of these three food components have
scientific reasoning as to
why they support keeping you feeling
satisfied for longer
so for instance protein is the
macronutrient that requires
the most work to digest meaning its
transit time in your gi tract
is longer than that of other foods
protein has also been proven to reduce
ghrelin levels
which if you remember from some of my
earlier videos is the hunger
stimulating hormone one study found that
participants who consumed
30 percent of calories from protein
compared to those who consumed 15
of calories from protein consumed almost
500 calories a day less
when given free rain to eat as they
please
as for fat fat is the strongest
inhibitor of gastric
emptying also staying in the stomach for
longer
and therefore keeping you feeling fuller
even longer
and finally fiber helps to reduce the
glycemic impact
of carbohydrate-containing foods by
slowing down transit time
delaying stomach emptying preventing
blood sugar crashes
and reducing hunger so yes to fiber
protein and healthy fats in some
combination
in most meals and most snacks now tip
three
is to dress up those naked carbs
we've discussed limiting naked carbs as
a strategy for folks with pcos in my
video right here
but i actually think that this is a
really valuable mindset for
everyone to get on board with naked
carbs are foods
like white bread desserts white rice etc
in other words their foods lacking the
hunger crushing combination
so this is really just another way of
conceptualizing the hunger crushing
combination
as everyone will respond to different
imagery
and strategy but my suggestion is to
combine your naked carb
with some protein and or fat to help
boost the satiety factor
and slow the blood sugar and insulin
response
for example if you like white bread have
your white bread
i'm not gonna force you to give it up or
switch to a fermented sprouted bread if
that is not enjoyable to you
but smear that bread with some natural
nut butter and top it off with berries
or throw on some mashed avocado and an
egg this is not only going to help to
stave off hunger a lot longer
thereby reducing the likelihood of a
snack attack
but it will also keep your insulin
levels from jolting up and down
now tip four is to slow down
and tune in so i know i know i need to
take my own advice as i admit
that since becoming a parent i've become
the fastest
eater of life
it's not good for my digestion my
enjoyment of food
and if i was trying to actively lose
weight which i'm not
it wouldn't be good for that either one
review of the literature
did find that eating slower was
associated with eating less
while other research suggests that fast
eaters are more likely to gain weight
compared to
slower eaters this is most likely
because it takes about 20 minutes or so
for your stomach to communicate to your
brain
that you're satisfied and i don't know
about you but
i do not need 20 minutes to polish off a
pint of
ben and jerry's so my suggestion is to
carve out time as much as you can for
you to sit down
and enjoy your meal if that means you
need to pencil meal times into your day
planner
or set a google calendar alert so that
they're not just like an afterthought
do it now i want you to imagine your
hunger
like a gas gauge ask yourself where are
you
on the hunger scale from 0 to 10
before you start eating as you eat tune
into your hunger and ask yourself
again where are you now if you started
out of two or three and maybe you're
halfway through what's on your plate
are you a five now are you a six are you
still a three
it's okay not to see an abrupt shift or
even be able to recognize what it feels
like
to satisfy your hunger yet this is
something that definitely takes
a lot of practice to hear especially if
you spent a lot of time
really heavily restricting but now keep
eating
until you feel at a place that is
comfortable for you for some people that
might be a six or seven or an
eight especially for a lot of
experienced intuitive eaters
but for others it might feel really
uncomfortable to be
anything less than a ten that's okay too
i don't want to turn this into the
hunger fullness diet
but you might find that with enough data
collection
and enough mindfulness that maybe a 10
no longer feels
so good anymore you're never going to
know though of course if you just
rush through the meal and miss those
early warning signs that you're full
so that brings me to tip number five get
rid of eating distractions
even if you're eating at a snail's pace
it's hard to tune
into your body's internal cues if you're
surrounded by
external distractions i'm talking about
your phone your computer
tv driving walking doing all the things
at once as i admittedly have attempted
hashtag parenthood but we do know that
distracted eating is often one of the
biggest triggers for mindless eating
an analysis of the research found that
folks who ate with distractions
ate 10 percent more than those who ate
without distractions
it not only seems to have an impact on
how much you eat during the distracted
meal
but also in subsequent meals as well
as we often forget that we even ate or
how much we ate
it's like my hubby who will tell me that
he didn't eat anything all day
but then i've watched him eat a bagel
banana apple cheese and like half a
rotisserie chicken
while taking business calls over the
kitchen sink when we eat on autopilot
the food just kind of somehow makes it
into our mouths
so power down and invest in the time to
eat
uninterrupted and then use that mental
bandwidth
to refer back to that hunger scale from
within okay
folks on to tip six meal
prep because we're not great at making
mindful decisions when we're
ill-prepared
if we go back to that analogy of our
body as a car
and her hunger being the gas gauge it's
really hard to find the best deal on gas
if we haven't mapped out our route
when we get desperate we're likely to
overspend at
the bougie full-service station
the same goes for food and nutrition i
know we're all busy
but i do see meal prep as a very small
investment
so everyone does meal prep differently
some people like to pick
a few recipes and then make a big batch
of like a few full meals
to be divvied up into containers for the
week
personally i get bored of this i also
find it makes it really hard to honor my
cravings in the moment
because i feel obligated to eat like
five days of the same recipe
that maybe i was craving a whole week
ago
so i prefer to make meal components
and then combine them in different ways
throughout the week
so for example i might grill up a bunch
of chicken breasts and bake off some
tofu
make a big pot of quinoa or rice
and then chop up and roast a ton of veg
then i have the building blocks for
different salads
soups stir fries and sandwiches that i
can mix and match with you know like a
different sauce or garnish
so next is tip seven do a fridge and
pantry
makeover no i'm not actually saying that
you need to go
on a kitchen detox and throw all the
junk
before your diet begins i actually find
that in a lot of cases
this tends to trigger a last supper
binge
where you know you're thinking oh my god
i gotta eat all the chips and all the
ice cream in the house today
because diet starts tomorrow i'm
actually suggesting
that you simply reorganize things to
make
more nutritious foods more convenient
and more accessible
for me this is kind of an extension of
the meal prep tip
but it doesn't necessarily require more
cooking which is great
i always recommend washing and prepping
lots of nutritious stuff
and then placing it front and center in
the fridge or
pantry so that the moment hunger hits
it's the most
intuitive and convenient choice to make
if you really want a little chips or
some ice cream
it's okay to keep them in the house but
place them somewhere
where you'd have to actively seek them
out
not just constantly grab them because
they're the first thing that you see
again this encourages us to be more
mindful
and deliberate about our food choices
even more indulgent ones
which will in turn usually lead to
greater satisfaction
and less mindless overeating all right
tip number eight
approach trigger foods wisely if you've
made it this far you know that i'm not a
fan of
overt restriction and that means that i
don't think that any foods
should be completely off limits even
when you're trying to lose weight
if i was coaching on intuitive eating
and improving somebody's relationship
with food
or disordered eating recovery i would
suggest
allowing yourself said trigger food
every day and this may work for a lot of
people
who are trying to lose weight who have a
history of yo-yo dieting
so to explain this i'll share my story
when i was struggling with food my
trigger was
sugary cereal i was obsessed so as part
of my healing process
i started to just make it part of my
routine
i challenged myself to have a bowl of
sugary cereal
every morning without guilt or shame
until eventually the novelty kind of
wore off
now i have no interest in sugary cereal
when
it's in the house in fact i sign up for
a nostalgic cereal of the month delivery
club
and i have only had like a handful of
each box
having said that i also understand that
not everyone is at a point in their
relationship with food
where they feel confident having all of
their trigger foods just
hanging around so in this case
particularly in the context of
weight loss i would suggest either
mindfully
and intentionally planning to buy them
or go out for them and when you do
enjoying them
guilt-free my friend abby langer author
of the new book
good food bad diet calls this awareness
not restriction so yeah to me it's like
you're aware that this food is easy for
you to overeat
so you're being intentional and mindful
as you enjoy it
but you're still approaching it with
permission so it's not to trigger a
binge restrict cycle all right moving on
to tip nine
make water your bff so i think it's a
really
common piece of diet advice to not drink
your calories when trying to lose weight
which often follows that you should
avoid all juice
soda alcohol and sugary coffee drinks my
approach is to choose water for
hydration purposes
and to work everything else into your
diet
the same way that you would like a fun
ice cream cone with friends or
family friday pizza night the reason why
i'm more intentional about limiting
calorie-laden beverages compared to food
is that
we know it's easier to override our
natural hunger and fullness cues
when we drink our calories compared to
eating them
there are a few potential reasons for
this but experts believe that
cognitively
people have a harder time deriving
psychological satisfaction from drinks
because they just mindlessly chug them
back while we interact longer with food
through
smelling and biting and chewing and
intentionally swallowing
liquids also travel faster through the
gi tract so
they alter satiety and hunger hormones
like ghrelin
differently than food especially if it's
a drink with
little to no protein fiber or fat
research suggests that even when eating
intuitively
we just don't fully compensate for the
calories that we consume in liquids by
eating less food and as a result it's
easy to gain weight when drinking a lot
of calories in fact
one study on over 50 000 women found
that those who increased their intake of
sugar sweetened drinks from
one a week to one per day added 358
calories daily
and gain significant weight while women
who reduce their intake
cut 319 calories now if juice is your
thing
or you need like double cream and double
sugar in your coffee to function
in life then of course work that into
your day
as you would anything else fun that will
make your eating pattern
more sustainable and enjoyable i'm also
not going to get into the hierarchy
of healthfulness of beverages i'm well
aware that juice contains
more micronutrients than pop but what
i'm saying
is to choose water for hydration whole
foods for nutrients
fiber and satiety and sugar sweetened
beverages for
pleasure flavor and fun on to tip 10
soul search to find your beloved food
faves when you've been dieting
restrictively for a really long time
it's not uncommon for any
stereotypically
demonized or bad foods to become
overwhelmingly alluring you know you're
on the paleo diet and told you can't
have dairy
and even though maybe you never cared
much for ice cream before
you suddenly find yourself binging on it
and just can't stop
so take some time to figure out what you
actually
truly like this goes for so-called
healthy foods as well as the alleged
junk
through this you'll maybe discover what
special foods you'll enjoy
fully and more mindfully that will
result in feeling truly satisfied
rather than continually going on a hunt
for what you
really want and that also means diving
deep
to determine what diet alternatives are
sufficient alternatives
and which are not if you love halo top
great
but if eating a pint of halo top
triggers a satisfaction hunt for the
real deal
and in the process you need to eat a bag
of chocolate chips
a few low-fat popsicles and then plow
through your ben
jerry's probably not a great choice so
figure out
what foods you truly want and enjoy
and work them strategically into your
week all right so on to tip 11
focus on stress and sleep
now this tip deserves a whole video in
itself and also i know i'm a hypocrite
i've got the worst
sleep and stress patterns but i'll try
to keep this brief
long story short there is solid evidence
that
skimping out on these basic acts of
self-care
can be detrimental to weight loss
efforts evidence suggests that
lack of sleep can increase our hunger
hormone ghrelin
reduce our satiety hormone leptin and as
a result
can increase appetite and potentially
our weight
it may also interfere with the reward
center in the brain
resulting in greater cravings for higher
sugar
and higher fat foods it's therefore not
surprising that
a six-year prospective study found that
those who slept less than five
hours or more than nine hours a night
we're 35 percent
and 25 percent more likely to experience
a
five kilogram weight gain over six years
respectively
likewise we have ample evidence to
suggest
that increases in the stress hormone
cortisol
is associated with weight gain over time
this
increase in cortisol tends to result in
us gravitating towards
more accessible food because you know we
likely lack
the mental energy to plan and prep and
cook not to mention
we use food as a coping mechanism for
said stress
but one study also found that women who
reported
one or more stressors within a 24-hour
period
burned over a hundred calories less than
non-stressed women
so there is apparently some metabolic
alterations happening as well which is
really interesting
all that said i know from my own
experience with insomnia
and anxiety that this is all easier
said than done and that the mere thought
of
not sleeping or being stressed causing
weight gain
that can be enough to actually
perpetuate more stress and insomnia
so it can become a vicious cycle and i
would need a whole video
to help you unpack solutions for this
but i bring it up to give you some
hopeful encouragement to prioritize your
mental health
because so much of weight loss is not
just about choosing
kale over cookies and that brings me to
tip number 12
acknowledge your emotional eating
patterns and intercept
again this is a big big topic so i'm
really just going to scratch the surface
here
but in the words of my partner in crime
abby langer
try not to weaponize food it's normal
and healthy to eat in response to
emotions sometimes since
food is intrinsically and socially
linked
to celebration mourning culture and more
but when it becomes our only coping
mechanism to deal with our emotions
it becomes a dangerous weapon so try to
experiment with other coping strategies
for difficult times like
journaling walking hot shower
doodling meditation or talking to a
friend
and if you're finding yourself
consistently turning to food to manage
your emotions
a licensed therapist can definitely help
all right moving on to tip 13
choose whole foods more often
i don't believe in setting arbitrary
guidelines or rules on
how much of your diet should be from
whole unprocessed or mentally processed
foods
like yogurt or frozen fruit versus ultra
processed
snack foods or fast foods there is no
quality evidence that i'm aware of that
would inform a
hard and fast ratio like this and i
really just see it as another rule to
obsess over
and inevitably break so
my advice instead is to think of
convenience foods as
assistance to the whole foods doing the
heavy lifting in your diet
if that store-bought ranch dressing is
going to help you get a salad on your
plate
eat the damn ranch if popping a frozen
pizza into the oven once a week means
that you help reduce your stress
and get to bed at a reasonable hour
pizza party it is
pizza party focus on the majority of
your diet coming from whole
or minimally processed foods and let go
of any guilt associated with the rest
next is tip 14 move your body in ways
that feels
good i actually think it's helpful to
decouple
our association of exercise with weight
loss
yes of course exercise contributes to a
caloric deficit
which in turn can enable weight loss but
research suggests that
exercise doesn't contribute as much as
we might like to think to weight loss
efforts
and putting too much stock into it can
likely be detrimental
by giving people a false sense of
entitlement to extra calories because
they put in the work having said that we
know there are
tons of benefits to exercise
even if weight loss isn't one of the
most significant ones
so my suggestion then is to just focus
on
movement you enjoy you don't have to
fill a bucket of sweat
for it to count ultimately if you don't
enjoy the movement you're not going to
stick to it
or you're going to let it encourage
overconsumption as a reward
for a punishing regimen so incorporate
some daily movement into your day as an
act
of self-care ideally something to
support metabolic muscle like some
resistance training
but ultimately make it something that
you can stick to
for life and finally tip number 15
be kind to yourself think of this
journey as
a marathon not a sprint please
do not make it a sprint because if your
running skills are anything like mine
there's a good chance you're gonna fall
on your face and never want to
run again in other words if you rush it
statistically
you're way more likely to gain that
weight right back
and since we need to look at this as a
long game
i also don't recommend weighing yourself
too often and for some
maybe not at all the scale is just one
tool that may be supportive for some
people
and toxic for others so everyone will
have success markers that work best for
them
but if the weight loss stalls please do
not freak out
you're not failing so do not give up and
forego
any progress that you've made in the
healthy habits that you formed
shift the focus to other markers of
success at least temporarily
to help you maintain momentum even if
the number on the scale isn't what you
want to see
weight loss is so complicated and as
much as we want to simplify it to
calories in and calories out
our bodies often have other plans so the
best thing that we can do
is to work with our body not against it
and give ourselves some grace as you can
see my goal with these gentle nutrition
and lifestyle suggestions
is to shift the focus away from denial
and restriction
and toward more additive considerations
that focus on
self-care nourishment and optimizing
nutrition
a reminder that this is not an
exhaustive set of nutrition tips
and really if you're looking to find
solutions that work for you
you'll want to work with a dietitian for
personalized care
but if you're sick of the extreme diet
roller coaster and associated weight
cycling
i hope this video offered some
evidence-based long-term
lifestyle and behavior changes that you
can consider and that is all that i have
for you guys today folks
thank you again to wild for sponsoring
this video if you liked it be sure to
give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on what you'd
like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you